oh [ __ ] what do I do
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you better run it's
put bring it on
I'm not scared not even a little bit
okay I'm scared I'm scared ah just
kidding
yeah yeah
[ __ ] me
go oh my god
well I got eco eat eat
Oh give me something stand on
oh my god oh god oh god haha ha [ __ ]
yeah not some monster trying to trick me
well who's there
now who's a [ __ ] oh oh oh oh what a
[ __ ] that oh my god oh look at it oh
no no I mean yeah I fight you get out
here
shucks yeah you don't know haha who was
that who do you think you are me
no one's me no one's as tough as I am
hahahaha all there's no door oh there's
no door give me a dog you man damn door
ah thank you thank you I don't care go
away I'm protecting myself
but two points yes one more try
boom yeah oh what the hell
yeah bounced off the grill I will leave
okay
huh I will stay Mustang Oh God ha ha
shut up stop with the music oh god I
could have killed it oh my god right
there so ugly
Oh God so ugly oh is it naked oh I think
he's naked
oh no I'm not go go go whoo well you go
slow as you know we left off with me yet
again kicking the ass of many like uh uh
I know B you didn't want to play go that
way
ah get back I got a chair you'll miss me
I got a chair oh god I hit him hit him
in the face with a chair dude [ __ ] yeah
oh no not another one oh my god oh my
god laughs oh my god hidey-hidey-ho on
my way to the kitchen oh not again
huh go away go away I have a I have a
chair again you didn't like that last
time like even glass system what's going
up what whole chair up your butt oh shut
up I got a chair back off
yeah hey my chair ah
what why
what Daniel you are so beyond I don't
even know I don't even know I don't even
God my chair
need a chair yeah that's right back off
huh oh no no not that way oh oh god he
sounds so fat oh he sounds fat oh what's
up there
Oh dead rat live rat dead okay hahaha no
door oh by the poisonous mushrooms yeah
that's a good idea
moving forward backwards moving
backwards yep haha I'm the man I'm the
man with the plan
[ __ ] burn follow-on oh my god bringing
on my first victim who wants some huh is
it oh [ __ ] I get to hit get the hammer
[ __ ] off what the hell oh oh god is it
chasing me
oh [ __ ] me oh god oh [ __ ] me Oh get out
of here good you're chasing me isn't it
Jason I don't know
stop shaking oh [ __ ] it is Oh God
all right right oh no now right now
right laughs ha ha
this isn't so bad bring it on yeah
I'm tough go away I'm not water hot
water not water water bad and right
there right there good right there
one event wait a minute wait a minute
butter butter by the way they're all out
of it what a bit out of it
okay all right yeah yeah lookin fast for
you what's going on what's going on yeah
nothing
nothing yeah you got nothing oh what's
that oh that doesn't look so bad
all right bring it on ah ha ha no no no
ah give me da Gama yeah ha ha ha ha oh
god he's patrolling oh oh go faster Oh
go faster
no right now oh [ __ ] no oh oh oh man
dumb all those dumb where am i where am
I going
I don't know I go I go I go I go Missy
and a barrel in the face you bastard
chop ah ok ok I'm ok
ok run Oh run Oh run Oh ok yeah oh
nothing nothing nothing whatsoever I
Estelle there oh you getting down here
I'm getting nothing
oh go away go away go away go away